So anyways,
Abraham sends his eldest servant off to his,
the place that God has granted him to find a wife.
And interestingly it,
the borders of the promised land are quite similar to the current borders of
Israel in these are estimates,
right?
Based on on the biblical,
and I didn't mean that's not a fluke obviously,
but it's interesting to see the concordance between these ancient stories and
the present day world.
So I thought that was very interesting.
And it shows once again that the past,
you think the past is the past,
but it's not,
it's,
it's still here,
it's embedded in the present.
You know,
just like the future in somehow in some ways is folded up inside the president
waiting to unfold.
The past is all folded up inside the present too.
So anyways,
the servant goes to,
yeah,
the land that he's been charged to go to and,
and he,
he's,
he's trying to figure out how in the world am I going to find a good wife for
Isaac?
I mean,
I don't know any of these people.
And so he has this little dialogue that's presented in the form of a prayer I
suppose.
Um,
and he thinks,
well,
I'm going to go to the place where you water,
where people get water and water the animals.
Um,
cause that's a place where everyone gathers.
So that's a good place to find someone.
And,
and it,
it's not a place of fun and lightness and relaxation and impulsivity.
It's a place of,
of life sustaining work.
And then he thinks something like,
well what would a decent girl do at a watering place?
And he thought,
well maybe she would offer a stranger some water and also offer to water the
camels because that would be brave to approach the stranger and that generous.
And then indicative of,
of the willingness to make an effort.
And when you know that a camel,
I think he took 10 camels.
It was quite a few camels anyways,
not just one.
And that a candle can drink 20 gallons of water.
And Rebecca,
who was drawing water from the wet turns out to be Rebecca is drawing water from
the well,
which was hard,
right?
Because water's heavy.
And you have to lift it up and it's 10 cows,
camels.
And so that's like 200 gallons of waters.
So,
you know,
she has to put herself out a fair bit in order to make this stranger happy.
And so that's what happens.
And then
serve it has brought along gifts and that sort of thing.
And anyways,
Tilapia,
long story short,
uh,
Rebecca agrees to come back to come back with the servant and Mary Isaac.
And so.